tach zusammen herzlich willkommen zu zdf
heute live über die aktuellen ereignisse
im westen deutschlands aktuell
betroffenen ja besonders
nordrhein-westfalen rheinland-pfalz nach
wie vor das tief bernd hat zwar
mittlerweile aufgehört das land mit
starkregen zu überfluten aber die
auswirkungen dieses unwetters und dieses
starkregens sind sichtbar und langsam
jetzt wird klar wie schwer tatsächlich
die schäden sind die zahl der todesopfer
steigt quasi minütlich an immer wieder
werden die zahlen nach oben korrigiert
aktuell reden wir von über 90 toten die
gesichert sind 93 an der zeit die grad
im raum steht
über 50 menschen sind wohl in rheinland
pfalz ums leben gekommen unter anderem
in einem heim für behinderte in sind
sich dort sollen zwölf menschen ums
leben gekommen sein die nicht mehr vor
den fluten gerettet werden konnten
aktuell dramatisch ist die lage in
erftstadt das ist bei köln
dort sind viele häuser unterspült wurden
mehrere schon eingestürzt und es sollen
zurzeit nach angaben der
bezirksregierung 15 menschen
eingeschlossen seien in ihren häusern
die rettungskräfte sind wohl auf dem weg
aber die situation ist sehr
unübersichtlich
wir schreiten gleich zu unserem reporter
nach nordrhein westfalen und nach
rheinland pfalz fragen und kommentare zu
dieser dramatischen situation wie immer
sehr gerne in die dafür vorgesehenen
kommentarspalten oder hier an diese
e-mail seite erfreute - live at zdf.de
wir gucken dann was sie mitnehmen wir
warten außerdem oder wir erwarten besser
gesagt gegen 12 uhr eine erneute
pressekonferenz der nordrhein
westfälischen regierung von
ministerpräsident laschet auch dahin
werden wir dann schalten jetzt aber
gucken wir uns mal einen kurzen
überblick an der letzten stunden von
moritz neues
schult im landkreis ahrweiler am tag
nach der unwetterkatastrophe wird das
ausmaß der naturgewalt hier besonders
deutlich sichtbar
der kleine ort zählt rund 700 einwohner
heute liegt er in trümmern
vier häuser wurden komplett weggespült
von zwei weiteren steht nur noch die
hälfte
es ist tatsächlich wirklich eine
katastrophe und das leid nimmt immer
weiter zu
wir haben inzwischen jetzt im rheinland
pfalz über 50 tote zu beklagen aber
immer noch menschen die vermisst sind
viele einsatzkräfte sind natürlich jetzt
bei aufgaben arbeiten aber an anderen
orten und stellen geht es immer auch
noch darum menschen zu suchen sie zu
retten wie viele menschen in den
gebieten um style noch vermisst werden
kann derzeit niemand sagen viele sind
nicht erreichbar es gibt keinen
handyempfang keinen strom mancherorts
wird sogar das trinkwasser knapp
rettungskräfte sind ununterbrochen im
einsatz die bewohner getroffen so viel
wasser habe ich in meinem ganzen leben
sind seit 34 jahren hier
wir haben hochwasser gehabt ja aber das
hier ist alles weg gesprochen
alles kaputt
halbe million schaden
auch im benachbarten nordrhein-westfalen
bleibt die lage angespannt die zahl der
toten stieg auf 43 dramatische meldungen
kommen am vormittag aus der stadt
südlich von köln häuser seien
eingestürzt sgb todesopfer verzweifelte
notrufe von eingeschlossenen menschen
sie können derzeit nur teilweise mit
booten evakuiert werden vielen können
die retter zur stunde nicht helfen
ja also dramatische bilder wir schalten
jetzt zu thomas münden der ist nicht in
erftstadt aber doch in der nähe in
jülich thomas was kannst du uns über die
situation dort vor ort aktuell noch
sagen hast du mehr rausbekommen können
also es scheint hat sich so zu sein dass
die kommunikationswege vor allen dingen
in erftstadt total zusammengebrochen
sind es gibt kaum handy empfangen
ich habe mehrfach versucht die
stadtverwaltung anzurufen mehrfach
versucht die kreisverwaltung anzurufen
man kommt nirgendwo durch es geht oder
es gibt die information dass inzwischen
das technische hilfswerk mit 400 helfern
aus baden württemberg auf dem weg nach
erftstadt sei das sei schon seit gestern
die helfer seien einsatzbereit und
wartet jetzt auf die letzte anforderung
was man gesehen hat auf den fotos auf
den hubschrauber bildern die ich mir bis
jetzt noch anschauen konnte von hier aus
war das tatsächlich irgendwie am ende
eines feldes mehrere häuser schlichtweg
gerutscht sind tatsächlich verschwunden
sind in einem krater in einem wasser in
einem in einem quasi tümpel jetzt
mittendrin stehen
da guckt teilweise noch die spitze raus
vielleicht sind sie auch ganz weg es
gibt sehr wenig informationen was
festzustehen scheint dass noch leute in
diesen ruinen sitzen und dass die kräfte
die im moment vor ort sind
augenscheinlich große probleme haben
oder zu wenig motor haben man kommt wohl
nur mit dem boot an die häuser heran um
dann tatsächlich dort rettungsmaßnahmen
einzuleiten
die frage die sich also stellt ist
wie man da jetzt weiter vorgeht es wird
das können wir unterstellen sicherlich
alles getan um so schnell wie möglich zu
helfen aber es scheint so schwer zu sein
weil niemand damit gerechnet hat dass es
durch diese unterspülungen zu einem
derart massiven gelände abbruch kommen
konnte oder kommen könnte und das ist
wohl das hauptproblem sind aber gerade
mal die karten abgeguckt die man ja so
auf dem handy hat also in und um
erstattet ist alles herum abgesperrt da
kommt man überhaupt nicht mehr rein noch
raus wie ist denn die lage wo du gerade
bist in jülich sieht hinter dir zwar
sehr voll aus aber einigermaßen sicher
es ist sonst enden wir hier nicht das
ist einigermaßen sicher die nacht war
kritisch gestern haben gegen mitternacht
begann die rurtalsperre überzulaufen
muss man sich vorstellt talsperre ist
ein relativ moderne tat sperre da wird
die talsperren wand auf keinem
verbrechen aber sie war einfach so voll
dass es dann über den rand geschwappt
ist wie bei der badewanne und dieses
über den rand schwappen hat sich dann
verstärkt über die nacht und ist in
wellen in die rur hineingeflossen die ja
sowieso schon hochwasser führt weil eben
die ganzen kleinen nebenflüsse in sie
hinein fließen und natürlich weil es
eben auch stark geregnet hat da sieht
man jetzt hinter mir die ruhe ist
normalerweise höchstens ein drittel so
groß und man kann sagte der
bürgermeister der stadt jülich eben mann
sondern es nicht aber man kann
normalerweise im sommer barfuß dadurch
geben deshalb war dir immer ohne h
das ist riesig so hat dieser fluss das
ist genau das ist die ruhe ohne haar die
in der eifel die die eifel rur sozusagen
was klar ist was klar wurde die gefahr
bestand eben dass dieser fluss so hoch
steigt dass er diese brücke hier
überflutet und von dieser brücke aus
liegt die altstadt von jülich ein
bisschen tiefer und dann wäre das alles
in die altstadt hinein gelaufen da hat
man die ganze nacht gesagt irgendwie das
wollen wir nicht riskieren die leute die
hier in unmittelbarer nähe wohnen wurden
gebeten ihre wohnung zu verlassen es gab
keine zwangsevakuierung es wurde nur
gesagt schalten sie alle strom geräte ab
und verlassen sie wenn möglich ihre wohn
das haben die meisten getan
die dürfen aber inzwischen wieder
zurückkehren nachdem es jetzt als
letztes gehört habe die um die die
warnung vor diesem unkontrollierten
zufluss durch die ruhe wurde eben auch
aufgehoben das haben die wahren apps
alle eben bestellt ist und jetzt sehen
wir ja jetzt wird wie
was sich die leute eben angucken und
schauen wie sieht es hier aus wie brücke
bleibt aber das ist ganz klar noch
mindestens zwei tage gesperrt weil der
durchfluss unter der brücke immer noch
sehr stark ist und wenn mal ein richtig
fetter baumstamm hier kommt das hat man
eben mehr fahrzeuge standen dann merkt
man das schon dass die brücke auch so
einen leichten klocker macht und man
hört also wenn hier schwere baumstämme
oder schwere gegenstände durch die ruhr
gegen diese brücke getrieben werden die
blatt noch zu aber der rest der gefahr
scheint zumindest hier erstmal vorbei
steinbachtalsperre sieht ganz anders aus
heimerzheim da ist das ein natur
staudamm da ist oben wie sie drauf im
endeffekt nun wir haben ja gestern ein
hubschrauberflug fürs zdf gemacht und da
konnte man genau sehen da sind fünf von
diesen bedingungen sind aufgeplatzt 55
große risse im staudamm und da muss
heute statik heran sich das genau
anschauen ob nicht vielleicht dieser
stau damen zusätzlich verstärkt werden
muss ob man da was unternehmen kann um
den zu stärken oder ob er noch hält denn
wenn dieser staat am preis wird es
tatsächlich die steuer die talsperre
leerlaufen die steinbachtalsperre und
das wäre für die dörfer darunter
heimerzheim und so weiter und sofort
richtig katastrophal schalten dann hat
man einen kurzen überblick ich habe das
mal rausgesucht in der karten app hier
also teil steinbachtalsperre ist wenn
immer auf meinen rechner schaltet liebe
kolleginnen in der regie genau da also
hier ist bonn und die steinbachtalsperre
ist hier ich sie mal ran
dort kann man es besser sehen hier gibt
es dann auch schon die warnhinweise
überschwemmungen in westdeutschland also
das ist hier die große
steinbachtalsperre und wenn dann
natürlich dann diese staumauer berechnen
sollte oder risse bekommt dann wird das
hier in diese richtung ziemlich
schwierig thomas ich kann dir außerdem
gerade aus den agenturen noch berichten
dass sich jetzt in erftstadt die lage ja
weiter zuspitzen könnte der landrat des
rhein erft kreises
er hat über den kollegen von n tv gesagt
dass sie mit drei weiteren todesopfern
rechnen und was sie nicht wissen wer den
häusern verblieben ist und das wohl
weitere häuser zusammen stürzen können
und dann gibt es eine meldung
die finde ich ein bisschen skurril
vielleicht kannst du was dazu sagen was
du dass du denkst das
verteidigungsministerium hat nämlich auf
twitter darauf hingewiesen dass die
betroffenen regionen sich militärische
hilfe holen könnten und hat dann ein
formular angehängt hast du das gefühl
dass die hilfe tatsächlich schnell genug
und auch unbürokratisch genug kommt also
ich meinte man jetzt schon formulare
anhängen muss ist finde ich ein bisschen
skurril muss ich sagen würde ich jetzt
von hier aus einfach weil unter
dramatisch habe ich sagen kann uns sein
kann nur ein fake sein also kann ich
sagen dass man ein formular dafür
braucht was ich aus eigener erfahrung
weiß ich war selber statt bundeswehr
beim roten kreuz im katastrophenschutz
das ist alles sehr formalisiert und das
ist wahrscheinlich auch immer noch sehr
formalisiert man da sieht man daran dass
wir eine meldung im bekommen haben
400 thw helfer sitzen da und warten auf
anforderungen ja wenn jedoch da sind
warum helfen die da nicht
oder warum legen die nicht einfach los
muss das immer alles so geregelt werden
muss dass man alles formalisiert werden
da kann man sich darüber streiten und da
wird man im nachhinein auch ganz
deutlich noch kritik üben müssen
aber wir wollen hoffen dass es jetzt
einfach so schnell wie möglich los geht
so was ich musste aber das muss so sein
das ist kein fake ich habe die seite mal
aufgerufen hier noch mal gerne auf
meinen rechner schalten das ist das
verteidigungsministerium das ist der
offizielle account und hier steht
service suite die vom hochwasser
betroffenen regionen das formular zur
amtshilfe gibt es hier einfach formlos
beantragen und dann ist dort der link
also das ist dann doch ja tatsächlich
der weg wie hier in deutschland ja nur
den kopf schütteln das ist unglaublich
hier und wir können es gerne auch mal
zeigen bei mir auf dem rechner dann
könnt ihr auch sehen dass das ganze
nicht ausgedacht ist tatsächlich kein
fähig so sieht das ganze aus
das verteidigungsministerium hat hier
diesen link angehängt da kann man sich
den antrag dann angucken auf
hilfeleistung durch die bundeswehr im
rahmen des artikels 35 grundgesetz gut
also thomas ich danke dir für deine
einschätzungen und führt dann für deinen
seine expertise wir werden im laufe des
tages natürlich in diversen sendungen
und nochmal zu dir schalten für jetzt
aber erstmal vielen dank und wir
schalten weiter zu meinem kollegen bobby
gene der steht in schuld in rheinland
pfalz und
das bild hinter dir bobby das spricht ja
schon bände was sie da genau
ja wir sehen hier schuld tatsächlich
oder was davon übrig ist man kann es
tatsächlich nicht anders formulieren es
sind weite teile des ortes unterspült
überspülte worden
es gibt autos die hier auf dem dach
liegen oder unter geröll begraben
eine der wenigen intakten brücken noch
und mir hat ein anwohner erzählt dessen
haus weitestgehend verschont geblieben
ist dass das wasser bis unter den bögen
gestanden hat von der ahr und mehr oder
minder mit einer unglaublichen wucht
heraus geschossen ist
andy seitengebäude mitgerissen hat und
dementsprechend kann man sich vorstellen
was hier alles im argen liegt also es
sind mehrere gebäude eingestürzt es gibt
ganz viele die einsturzgefährdet sind
die lage muss jetzt heute vor ort weiter
bewertet werden der einsatzleiter von
der feuerwehr hat mir eben noch erzählt
dass es ein tagesordnungspunkt sie
möchten hier so schnell wie möglich mit
menschen vom thw expertinnen und
experten mit bausachverständigen durch
um sich einen überblick darüber zu
verschaffen welche gebäude können stehen
bleiben und welche müssen vielleicht
auch so schnell wie möglich abgerissen
werden weil sie ein ganz großes
sicherheitsrisiko sind da gibt es
natürlich noch andere komponenten die
mit reinspielen und nicht ohne sind denn
diese gebäude gehören ja auch immer
menschen und die müssen ihr okay dazu
geben dass ein vielleicht instabiles
gebäude eingerissen wird und das ist
eine entscheidung die sich allen
beteiligten sehr schwer fällt
das ist so der stand der dinge gerade es
wird jetzt auch versucht aufzuräumen der
einsatzleiter hat mir auch erzählt dass
es auch ein ganz wichtiger punkt heute
sie müssen versuchen hier vor ort die
infrastruktur die grobe infrastruktur
wieder herzustellen soll heißen wir
haben das gestern auch gesehen auf dem
weg nach schuld alleine gibt es viele
straßen die plötzlich enden weil er
mitten in kray also mitten in der straße
ein krater ist so dermaßen doll ist die
straße an dieser stelle vom wasser
unterspült worden und da gibt's dann
auch einfach mal kein durchkommen
wir selber haben auch sehr lange
gebraucht bis wir es hierhin geschafft
haben dass wir einen weg gefunden haben
das heißt also wieder herstellen der
infrastruktur ganz wichtiger punkt
da müssen alle da muss auch wirklich
schweres gerät run oder sind gerade
wieder bei der bundeswehr die ja eben
schon thema war
tatsächlich haben die einsatzkräfte ich
hier auch ein ich nenne es jetzt mal
antrag so habe ich das verstanden
gestellt und zwar auf ein räumfahrzeug
der bundeswehr
das soll bitte hierhin kommen also ohne
schweres gerät ist die situation hier
überhaupt gar nicht zu bewältigen also
die grobe infrastruktur kann gar nicht
ohne schweres gerät hergestellt werden
ob man hier in schuld dieses gerät von
der bundeswehr bekommt also dieses
räumfahrzeug das ist noch nicht geklärt
das soll sich heute hoffentlich im laufe
des tages entscheiden
aber wenn man sich schult anguckt und
viele andere ortschaften hier in der
gegend dann ist auch klar dass nicht nur
hier in schuld diese entsprechenden
mittel benötigt werden sondern an ganz
vielen anderen stellen auch und da liegt
der schluss natürlich nahe dass einfach
nicht genug equipment da ist um allen
gleichzeitig gerecht zu werden überhaupt
möglich ist dass so viele menschen ja
quasi im schlaf überrascht wurden das
ist ja vor allem nachts passiert also
haben da die warenketten nicht
ausreichend funktioniert sind die
behörden da einfach auch schlecht
vorbereitet gewesen
also ich glaube viele menschen hier
haben sich schon darauf eingestellt
haben dementsprechende maßnahmen auch
getroffen ist wir haben gestern und
heute mit menschen gesprochen die uns
erzählt haben
ja wir wussten ja dass ist diese
unwetterlage gab es gab ja die warnungen
und die haben dann das getan was ihnen
möglich war sie haben gesagt wir haben
alle also wenn sie ein mehrstöckiges
haus zum beispiel bewohnt haben dann
haben sie gesagt wir haben unsere
wertgegenstände unsere elektronikgeräte
all das was uns besonders wichtig war
auf die in die höheren etagen geschafft
also alles möglich raus aus dem
erdgeschoss aus dem keller was besonders
wichtig ist aber dass es dann trotzdem
sich so doll ausgewirkt hat dass am ende
das wasser so hoch gestiegen ist dass
sich menschen auf dem dachboden
verschanzen mussten um weil das die
einzig wirklich sichere
rückzugsmöglichkeit war das hat dann
doch keiner kommen sehen und da haben
die menschen dann auch gesagt ein mann
mit seiner familie wir haben das wasser
kommen sehen wir sind schon auf den
dachboden geflüchtet und konnten
eigentlich nur verzweifelt hier sitzen
und hoffen dass uns nichts passiert weil
gegen das wasser das immer näher kommt
und nach und nach das gebäude
einschließt und dementsprechend auch
fluchtwege abschneidet
man nichts machen da kann man nur
verzweifelt drauf gucken und hoffen dass
es sich halbwegs gut entwickelt diese
familie ist dann zum glück von der
feuerwehr mit dem boot gerettet worden
also insofern die menschen waren gewarnt
das ist aber dann solche ausmaße annimmt
dass das wasser mit einer solchen wucht
hierdurch drückt alles mit sich reißt
eine derartige verwüstung hinterlässt
damit haben die wenigsten gerechnet
das wird dann wahrscheinlich auch noch
mal eine frage sein die im laufe der
zeit aufgearbeitet werden muss
bei mir jetzt ist der kollege bobby
verschwunden das ist aber in ordnung
denn bei mir im studio ist mein kollege
ist intelli aus der halle daniel
wetterredaktion meteorologe und das ist
natürlich jetzt eine sache über die wir
sprechen müssen weiterhin sprechen
werden
ich habe hier mal wieder lieber erst
dann erstmal natürlich betroffene
kommentare von menschen die kräuterbeet
der oder die schreibt wann wird endlich
was für die natur und den klimaschutz
getan damit das nicht so weitergeht
es gibt viele betroffene meldungen bei
euch die sagen das ist schon echt
traurig was hier passiert man kann nur
hoffen dass sich das so schnell ich
wiederholt und furchtbar traurig vielen
dank an die vielen helfer ihr seid die
helden das möchten wir hier auch
unterstreichen also wird nicht jeder
freiwillige thw-helfer der gerade und
die gerade auf dem weg ist
vielen dank für euren einsatz aber es
denn es gibt natürlich genau die frage
man kann nur hoffen dass sich das wir
ständig wiederholt und hier eine
wortmeldung von einem user der sagt ich
lebe schon seit über 50 jahren in der
hochwasserregion hat aber noch nie
jemand interessiert heute ist es der
klimawandel unfassbar
warum fällt uns das so schwer dass
anzunehmen dass das tatsächlich was mit
der erwärmung der erde zu tun hast du da
irgendeine idee weil ihr sagt das ja
schon seit jahren
naja die wissenschaftler sagen sie auch
schon seit jahren es gibt ja unzählige
studien dazu dass ich weiter extrem auch
zu zu nehmen und dass sich die lage
zuspitzt die temperatur steigt die
menschen vom menschen verursacht
konzentration der treibhausgase in der
atmosphäre
die nimmt ja auch weiter zu also was
sollte sonst passieren außer dass die
temperatur steigt das erste mal einfach
grundsätzlich also ihr steckt klar die
klimakrise hinter warum die menschen das
nicht annehmen
naja man muss sagen wir haben seit
jahrzehnten
da haben wir eine desinformation aus der
sicht der ölindustrie zum beispiel dass
es auch wissenschaftlich wissenschafts
historische aufgearbeitet ist jetzt
keine behauptung von mir kann jeder
nachlesen
zum beispiel neben klassiker merchants
oft während quasi sich die
klimawissenschaft entwickelt hat gab es
eine desinformationskampagne und das war
ein regelrechtes rennen und das meiste
geld ist nun mal in dieser industrie
gewesen
diese industrie hat quasi die
gesellschaft damit infiltrierte also zum
beispiel das immer noch gesagt wird aber
die wissenschaft weiß dass noch gar
nicht ist natürlich unsinn natürlich
wissen sie das oder die sonne ist schuld
dass ja auch ein ganz beliebte
geschichte nur um dich anzuerkennen was
tatsächlich physikalisch eben das ist
was eben realität ist eine
realitätsverweigerung wie es sind das
also wenn man jetzt sagt okay die an
klar hochwasser gibt es nun mal wieder
werde ich nicht mehr wie dieses gibt es
auch immer wieder ich habe jetzt heute
gehört der deutsche wetterdienst sagt
okay das ist eigentlich ein jahrhundert
unwetter gewesen dass wir da erlebt
haben sollte eigentlich statistisch erst
100 jahren oder mehr wieder vorkommen
aber konnte man zum beispiel weil so
unwetter vor 10 oder 15 jahren noch vor
fünf jahren
das noch nicht so klar sagen dass das
mit dem thema wandel zusammenhängt und
das ist jetzt das erste wir herstellen
müssen okay das ist tatsächlich hat eine
ursache wirkung funktion oder war das
auch schon vor zehn jahren sind ja also
die klimawissenschaftler sagen es schon
länger dass extremereignisse zunehmen
werden allein der für die physikalische
grundlage
das warme luft mehr feuchtigkeit
aufnehmen kann und diese feuchtigkeit
die muss irgendwohin muss irgendwohin
und gerade bei kollektiven ereignissen
also wenn sich gewitter gebildet werden
ja da wird gerade dabei also wenn wenn
sich gewitter entwickeln dann wird diese
wärme die in dieser feuchtigkeit
gespeichert ist stichwort latente wärme
falls das jemand nachlesen möchte wird
diese wärme frei und heizt dann die
gewitter- und ja diese diese
aufsteigenden luftmassen quasi noch
weiter anderen das wird dann noch
extremer wobei bei diesem beispiel jetzt
mit unserem tief bernd war die luft ja
schon sehr sehr gesättigt das war eine
super feuchte luft die quasi dann zu
diesen heftigen flächendeckenden
regenfällen
dafür gesorgt haben ich glaube jetzt
hier trotzdem auch weiter kommentare so
gerne ewig oder sagt die wissenschaft
weiß es nicht zu 100 prozent wobei mein
bescheidenes wissenschaftsverständnis
sagt hundertprozentige sicherheit gibt
es in der wissenschaft ja wissenschaft
entwickelt sich immer weiter aber ich
frage mich warum sagt man sowas ja also
warum sagt man die wissenschaft weiß es
nicht 100 prozent ist es überhaupt
notwendig 100 prozent und woher weiß er
dass das die wissenschaft sagen wir mal
die anerkannte wissenschaft darum geht
es ja es geht nicht um einzelmeinungen
die quasi versuchen vielleicht aufgrund
ihrer eigenen agenda hier irgendwie
mitzumischen
die anerkannte wissenschaft sagt das
durchaus das kann man auch über
nachlesen auch in den letzten tagen
melden sich ja der deutsche wetterdienst
friederike otto hat dazu was gesagt das
ist die die top wissenschaftlerinnen die
quasi diese attribute uns forschung
veröffentlicht in ihrem team die zeigen
zum beispiel die hitzewellen zu nehmen
also temperatur kann man sehr gut zeigen
dass es damit zu tun hat weil sie nur
eine sache ist ein parameter die
temperatur bei solchen starkregen
ereignissen müsste man mehrere sachen
angucken da es schwieriger aber also
physikalische grundlagen kann man aber
nicht davon schieben also was heißt hier
100 prozent ist die feuchtigkeit nun da
nimmt diese feuchtigkeit zu nimmt die
temperatur zu also hier sind ganz klare
sachen also man man hinterfragt ja auch
nicht ob es die gravitation gibt oder
nicht
und übrigens gravitation wäre an dieser
stelle auch ein gutes beispiel
wo sollte eigentlich jetzt ja wo sollte
übrigens das wasser hinfließen
wenn es in solchen massen runterkommt es
wird natürlich den weg des geringsten
widerstandes suchen also das kleinste
rädchen kann man sagen wird anschwellen
und genau das passiert ja also man kann
auch solchen behauptungen eigentlich
auch entgegenstellen es wird auch nicht
die letzte katastrophe sein denn das
wasser wird wenn es zu extremen
ereignissen kommt wieder diese wege
suchen da habe ich nur wortmeldungen zu
dir passt gerne einigermaßen können wir
kurz mal zeigen wir auf dem rechner von
andrea schreibt der klimawandel ist
nicht schuld es geht und verantwortliche
die seit jahren
hochwasserschutzmaßnahmen für solche
fälle erarbeitet haben und
fehlt vielleicht einsatz nehme an andre
dass du davon ausgeht dass das halt
nicht ausreichend erarbeitet wurde oder
nicht ausreichend umgesetzt wurde das
für den klimawandel zu
instrumentalisieren ist widerlich also
hier und ich muss sagen das passt ein
bisschen in die linie von jens spahn der
tatsächlich gerade gesagt hat man sollte
jetzt diese katastrophe nicht
instrumentalisieren für den wahlkampf
aber gehen da vielleicht mal erst auf
diese klimaschutz auf diese
hochwasserschutzmaßnahmen du hast gesagt
dass das wasser sucht sich den weg des
geringsten widerstandes das ist ganz
normal dass ich das sollte jeder ich
sollte mir jeder anerkennen oder aber
würden solche katastrophen sich
vielleicht nicht so häufig wenn man
jetzt einfach mal vorsorgt hat auch der
innenminister gesagt wir müssen in der
vorsorge treffen dann ist zwar mehr
hochwasser da ist mehr starkregen da
aber es kommt halt nicht so ein großer
schaden zustande
naja vorsorgen ich meine das ist ja
jetzt nicht das kann ja auch nicht von
hand weisen man sollte natürlich mehr
vorsorgen die frage ist natürlich das
hatten der wissenschaftlerin jahr
gestern auch im heute journal gesagt die
frage ist natürlich wie leben wir
wir müssen natürlich berücksichtigen
dass diese ereignisse zunehmen werden
die temperatur wird weiter steigen und
wird auch weiterhin die wettersysteme
beeinflussen
das wissen wir und wenn man das
berücksichtigt dann muss man natürlich
auch für die zukunft sagen müssen wir
auch schauen wie wir wie wir weiter
leben wollen müssen wir an hängen leben
müssen wir in thailand leben direkt
neben einem rinnsal muss offensichtlich
dann zusammen kommt aber das ist jetzt
keine schuldzuweisung oder so sondern es
ist einfach eine feststellung was müssen
wir verändert wie müssen wir in der
zukunft leben
diese fragen müssen wir angehen aber
ganz ehrlich ich sehe da jetzt nicht
wirklich eine echte auseinandersetzung
damit und das instrumentalisieren die
frage ist ja wann sollten wir denn sonst
darüber reden oder umgekehrt wenn wir
die fakten weglassen er ist das dann
auch wahlkampf und für wen das ist ein
bisschen die frage ist ja auch dass eine
partei überhaupt gibt die wirklich
antworten auf alles hat bzw die
richtigen antworten auf alles ich schau
mal kurz ist eine sache die verstehe ich
nicht das ist kommt immer wieder
häufiger vor wenn wir jetzt hier über
solche sachen reden das dann userinnen
und user behauptungen in den chats
schreiben die sich sehr klug anhören und
informiert ich kann damit nichts
anfangen
deswegen habe ich erst dann da
vielleicht sagt dir das was die
hug studie steht hier sagte die was
jetzt 12.000 ausgewerteten studien von
wissenschaftlern käme zu einer 0,5
übereinstimmung bezüglich des
menschengemachten klimawandels sagte
dass irgendwas oder ist das eine
behauptung die wir ja jetzt dafür oder
dagegen also ich kenn ich habe die kug
studie schon mal gehört aber der
überragende teil der wissenschaft der
anerkannte teil alle institute auf
diesem planeten sagen die klimakrise
gibt es die erde erhitzt sich weiter wir
können es mit satelliten messen wir
sehen den temperaturen 12.000
wissenschaftler ich wüsste gerne wer
diese wissenschaftler sind in welchen
abhängigkeiten die zusammenhänge und für
was sie bezahlt werden also auch das
hatten wir ja auch ja wissenschaftler
bezahlt wurden von von industrie
ölindustrie das ist ja quasi in den 90er
jahren ganz massiv gewesen
und selbst jetzt ist ja wenn ja zum
beispiel positionen angegriffen die
eigentlich schon längst anerkannt sind
in der wissenschaft
ich sagte er diese
desinformationskampagne ist derart fed
gewesen muss man sagen in den letzten
jahrzehnten dass ihr einfach die
gesellschaft regelrecht infiltriert
haben wir warten jetzt weiter darauf
dass sich die regierung von nordrhein
westfalen also ein präsident armin
laschet noch mal äußert ich weiß ehrlich
gesagt nicht wieder jetzt grad der stand
ist vielleicht sagt mir die regie das
vielleicht noch mal aufs tor
aber ich kann schon mal feststellen dass
es jemals wieder große kontroversen gibt
hier wird auch wieder behauptet das
ganze wäre menschen gemacht menschen
manipuliert also da kommen wir diese
wetter maschinen das sind ganz klar
verschwörungs mythen denen man keinen
glauben schenken sollte aber vielleicht
gehen wir mal wirklich über das wetter
das kannst du das sagen also die
situation hat sich entspannt die variant
ist nicht mehr hoch aktiv ich habe mal
geguckt also es gab nicht mehr so große
gibt keine großen regengebiete mehr was
kommt in diesen tagen ja es wird sich
stabilisieren das hoch bei ernte sei ja
schon gestern so aus es wird nach und
nach abgedrängt werden es gibt noch
einige gewitter heute und morgen auch
quer über deutschland quasi aber diese
katastrophengebiete die bekommen jetzt
nicht mehr diese riesen regenmengen ab
weil diese situation er sich einfach
abgeschwächt hat es gibt noch gewitter
heute im tagesverlauf und morgen auch
aber in der kommenden woche stabilisiert
sich das ganze wetter das ist schon mal
eine gute nachricht zumindest für die
katastrophengebiete zum aufräumen
so also ich habe das gerade ehrlich
gesagt nicht ganz verstanden wie wir
weitermachen hier im stream
vielleicht kann ja nochmal kurz jemand
sagen ob die pressekonferenz
ich höre gerade die pressekonferenz in
düsseldorf vermutlich von armin laschet
wird erst um 12.30 stattfinden aber wir
haben aktuelle bilder aus sind sich dort
sind ja durch das unwetter zwölf
menschen in einem heim der lebenshilfe
ums leben gekommen hier sehen wir dieses
heim der lebenshilfe also auch komplette
verwüstung ich sehe die bilder zum
ersten mal muss ich euch jetzt auch
sagen
zwölf menschen sind dort ertrunken über
nacht weil diese überschwemmung so
heftig und so kurzfristig kam dass
niemand mehr ihnen helfen konnte das ist
natürlich besonders dramatisch weil es
sich hier um menschen mit behinderungen
handelt die in diesem heim untergebracht
waren die wahrscheinlich ohne fremde
hilfe auch gar nicht aus diesem heim
hätten fliehen können
das dann müssen wir uns tatsächlich
darauf vorbereiten dass solche
wetterphänomen jetzt häufiger komme aber
hey - häufiger das nächste große
unwetter ist in zehn jahren da oder der
nächste sommer sieht genauso aus
ich habe heute noch eine aktuelle studie
eben noch überflogen da wird es darauf
hingewiesen dass quasi der jetstream für
diese zusammenhänge verantwortlich ist
und nicht nur die die feuchtigkeit quasi
die vom mittelmeerraum kommt das so
abgeschottete tiefs in der zukunft
häufiger vorkommen und das verwundert
mich jetzt als meteorologe relativ wenig
weil letztendlich wenn der jet woanders
unterwegs ist kann es eben dazu kommen
dass so ein tief selbstständig
gestrandet unterwegs ist über über
europa zieht und dabei seinen unheil
anrichtet quasi ja wir müssen damit
häufiger rechnen extremwetter werden
weiter zunehmen wir sehen sie auch
global das ist ja jetzt man muss ja
sagen der jetstream ist ja auch eine
globale geschichte und man merkt
hier tut sich einiges was in den letzten
jahren und auch das wird wird sehr stark
untersucht da gibt es sehr viele
forschungen darüber und was man sagen
kann ist dass dieser jetstream immer
schwächer wird
vor allem in den sommermonaten und dann
kann es eben zu solchen ereignissen
kommen wenn quasi gewittertätigkeit und
regen am stärksten quasi dann ist ja ich
schon noch mal kurz in die kommentare
die presse auf die pressekonferenz
werden wir jetzt nicht mehr warten
einmal beschlossen das ist noch einer
halben stunde
die werden aber trotzdem auf jeden fall
live streamen auf heute de und auf den
üblichen plattformen diesmal gefragt
welche maßnahmen müssen beim klimaschutz
jetzt deutlich verschärft werden hörst
du na ja als erstes müssen die ursachen
bekämpfen also das aber das ist jetzt
nun auch wirklich alte ein alter hut
pariser haben müssen wir gar nicht mehr
darüber reden protokoll ja müssen wir
müssen einfach nur umsetzen damit quasi
die die spitze damit die klimakrise
gedämpft wird weil wir wissen ja wenn
wir auch wenn wir jetzt sofort aus den
fossilen energieträgern aussteigen also
kein kohlendioxid mehr emittieren
dann steigt die temperatur noch ein
bisschen an bildet eine kleine nase und
dann bleibt aber die temperatur auf
einem sehr hohen niveau und dieses hohe
niveau das ist ja weiterhin zerstört ja
also wir brauchen auch eine
klimaanpassung das heißt also das was
wir beim fckw den 90ern hatten wo sie es
hier nicht mehr in den kühlschränken
losen benutzen und dann haben wir
festgestellt dass ozon loch schloss sich
wiederwahl nicht mehr so viel fckw frei
gesetzt wurde
so eine rückwärts entwicklung werden
hier mit den co2 werten in der
atmosphäre in der stratosphäre nicht so
schnell nicht so schnell weil wenn man
das co2 abgibt dann wirkt es ja sofort
das ist ja direkt an und es ist hawass
über hundert jahre in der atmosphäre das
bedeutet das betrifft nicht nur dich und
mich nicht nur unsere kinder sondern
noch spätere generationen und auch diese
erhitzung wird die späteren generation
besonders hart treffen aber wir spüren
es ja auch jetzt schon
und übrigens fck wesen interessante
geschichte dieses montreal protokoll das
könnte man eigentlich fast auch schon in
der zukunft als pulverisiert sehen
es gibt eine neue studie vom
alfred-wegener-institut die besagt wenn
wir den klimaschutz
nicht effektiv und konkret umsetzen dann
bauen verschiedene zu also ist es zu
komplex hierzu erklären aber in der
arktis wird dann quasi das ozon abgebaut
vor allem der zweiten jahrhunderthälfte
ab 2050
das würde dazu führen dass wir nochmal
ganz andere probleme bekommen also wir
würden dann ein ozonloch in der
nordhemisphäre bekommen weil wobei die
jetzt gerade gesprochen haben das
ozonloch war ja hauptsächlich eine
antarktis auf der südhalbkugel
ja und das sind der nordhalbkugel das
würde quasi es würde sich quasi auch
öffnen und dann hätten wir wirklich
andere probleme so ich gehe noch mal
kurz auf was anderes das nichts mit dir
zu tun hat wir haben anfang der sendung
des streams darüber gesprochen dass das
verteidigungsministerium formulare
getwittert hat um zu sagen hier könnt
ihr euch hilfe kriegen das hat mich so
ein bisschen irritiert das hat den
kollegen thomas münten irritiert es gibt
aber auch hier durchaus wortmeldungen
zum beispiel von ralf schnell per mail
der sagt er ist äußerst verärgert
darüber dass wir uns darüber ja sooo
lustig gemacht hätten oder finde das
arrogante wir darüber gesprochen haben
denn das hat auch nachvollziehbar dass
bei der anforderung von amtshilfe
bestimmte informationen mitgegeben
werden müssen und dies in einem formular
abzufragen
er ist ein zweifelsfrei einfacher als
über überlastete telefonleitungen die
gleichen informationen mündlich
abzufragen
ich bin da vom prinzip bei dir lieber
ralf allerdings bin ich da irritiert bin
ich jetzt mal einfach so frei sprechen
darf darüber dass es ein formular gibt
was man irgendwie herunterladen
ausdrucken dann wieder irgendwohin
schicken müsste genau das ist ja ein
problem der digitalisierung das ist
meine private meinung sagte ich einfach
mal weil ich glaube da haben wir euch
noch ein bisschen bedarf so was könnte
schneller gehen wenn es zb über web
formulare funktioniert auch harald
hübner hat sich jetzt hier ein bisschen
verärgert gezeigt schreibt was ist denn
daran komisch die hilfe suchen über ein
formular einzureichen
es braucht eine struktur entscheidungen
wer zuerst kommt hilfe ohne
führungsstruktur endet im chaos und wir
haben in deutschland einen gut
organisierten katastrophenschutz
der ist auf dem weg das thw wir bedanken
uns noch mal bei all den helferinnen und
helfern die das jetzt ehrenamtlich
übernehmen die bundeswehr ist wohl auch
auf dem weg nichtsdestotrotz stellen
sich doch einige fragen warum ebenso
viele menschen von diesem hochwasser so
überrascht wurden und da würde ich dich
noch mal fragen ist dann gibt es
möglichkeiten
menschen schneller zu wahren umfassen
dazu waren damit die eben nicht in ihren
häusern eingeschlossen werden ich meine
wir kennen das von den feuersbrünsten
aus anderen regionen amerika oder sowas
da werden die menschen schnell gewarnt
und nun können die aus ihren häusern
fliehen ist das hier nicht möglich weil
die modelle nicht haben oder waren wir
da einfach nicht gut vorbereitet also
die vorhersagen waren ja relativ gut
muss ich ja sagen wir mehr davor gewarnt
bis zu 200 liter auf den quadratmeter
der deutsche wetterdienst hat ja
permanent gewarnt also das ist ein
extremes ereignis wird es waren ja
permanent extrem unwetterwarnungen also
das ist jetzt auch nicht so oft dass sie
über mehrere tage quasi alles schief
violett eingefärbt ist das hätte man
sehen können dass das da sich eine
katastrophe anbahnt kann man das auch
immer müssen es auch simulieren können
wo dann das wasser lang fließt und dann
zu sagen okay dieser strom wird an
fließen oder das ist das ist jetzt
natürlich die frage an einen hydrologen
nachweisen ob die das simulieren
sicherlich gibt es das simulationsmodell